comme dans le cas belge il y va du jeu
interne belge c'est le sel c'est la
constitution belge qui oblige le premier
ministre avant de signer l'accord
le vainqueur 2009 et la démocratie c'est
normal de demander de nous demander
l'accord de tous les partis de tous les
six parties de son pays
là dans d'autres pays ça n'existe pas
donc même les grands pays où il ya des
débats dans le fond on ne m'aime pas ce
débat dans le fond qu'en belgique jeu là
je crois que on est en train de la
belgique est en train de nous
ridiculiser en entier dans le monde
entier et nous ridiculise elle nous
ridiculise pas ce qu'on n'est pas on
n'est pas près d'une épave capable que
le chef de le chef d'état en belgique
signe ces accords là